your mom and dad when they saw you when
you first got into you've been in the
space of in four Wars and what you've
been doing for how long 30 years 28
years 25 years 29 years 29 years okay so
when you first got in I was 20 years old
you were 20 years old okay so what was
their initial reaction to was it like
Alex what are you doing and there was a
we believe in you we agree with you
you're talking too much but relax this
is you're going overboard what was their
reaction to this when you first got
started uh my dad for the first five six
seven years was just sometimes say you
need to be careful what you're doing and
you're gonna get killed doing this he
said one time he said I could have you
talk to some people and get you out of
this right now but he said I said the
government's bad he said they are bad
they got to do bad things to protect
this country they're in charge because
they're smart and and they're smarter
than us what a thing to say and and yeah
yeah they got to do bad things to
protect the country yeah